or je suis un peu étonné parce qu'on va
a cru qu elle est loin d'être idiote en
fait c'est très maligne elle fait un
buzz utilise tout ça alors non site
intelligence mais par contre elle est
content moi à côté de la plaque au
niveau du droit pardon de le dire mais
quand on business on regarde un minimum
si la loi parce que si tu es hors la loi
ton business il s'effondre donc en fait
là ya plein de choses qui vont pas ya
pas qu n'y a pas qu'une chose je passe
une heure devant nous et cyril femme et
non mais dis non il ya plein d'exemples
on l'a dit tout à l'heure à la un site
internet de vente en ligne tu es tu
vends là dessus il ya aucune mention
légale c'est-à-dire quand on veut
quelque chose on peut pas tous émus
vendée créé un site on doit être soit
commerçants soient entrepreneurs si
c'est le cas on indique son numéro vert
c est son numéro de tva ses coordonnées
ci fais pas ça c'est pas grave c'est
quand même un an de prison avait juste à
75000 euros d'amendé et si on était
trois fois mais je vous le dira mais en
fait elle n'est pas là pour faire du
business pas pour faire du buzz un
message internet choses apparemment été
fait et c'est pour ça que ça m'avait
fait très peu nombreuses pour fermer
alors pas tenu une demi de moi
j'aimerais juste savoir pourquoi cigale
devant de l'autre l'autre sont pas
justes ouais ça je tenais pour faire du
buzz mais comme j'ai dit hier soir en
plateau c'est le buzz qui vient à moi on
n'est pas les
[Applaudissements]
nôtres ce qu'il faut comprendre que même
c'est que voilà c'est bien bossé c'est
presque c'est marrant après le futur cas
là assez chic et sympa sais c'est pas
grave en soi sauf légalement si c'est
super grave tandis que ça ce que ça va
engendrer haut niveau la loi tu n'as pas
pardon mis deux délégations sur ton site
ça c'est 15 euros 75
les contrôles
et les gars c'est pas dire marcelo du
bas l'eau du bac avec kelly l'illégalité
gala en robes à l'eau du bain on sait
qu'on a prise un problème alors c'est
quoi tient un principe en france qui dit
quoi droit de vendre de bêtise et de
monnayer une partie de coop ou un
produit de son corps ça veut dire quoi
dire que par exemple de perdre la
semence
je ne sais pas alors c'est bien pas de
faire
non pas sur son site cyril elle dit lou
du bas quand on clique sur en savoir
plus et indiquent les
dirigeants sont bas
gires dans le bain c'est indiqué comme
ça il s'agit et c'est ça ce qui devrait
leur en fait on imagine que si j'étais
que de l'eau ça va ça voudrait pas 1106
rumeur fait que celle que l'un avec les
canards comme céder les vidéos n'ont pas
dire oui mais
lui même s'ils n'ont pas fait pour ça
que ça de la valeur gardant les mêmes au
monde ça comme ça c'est interdit
cent vingt ans à boca et donc ça c'est
quand il parle alors pour toi vite donc
c'est certain deuxièmement il ya un
problème aussi et après on frise aussi
là aussi avec l'escroquerie pourquoi
parce que j'étais sur le site tout c'est
un site il perd basique en est à trois
pages monfils kaka 12 on va le faire
mais ça c'est pas de problème la partie
manque taux légal c'est pas grave tant
mieux si ça lui donne un nom mais en
plus j'aime bien je dis ça aussi les
moulins et là des secouristes non ça
c'est qu'en fait quand on va sur le site
soit on achète une petite culotte c'est
100 euros hockey papa soit il ya l'eau
du bain c'est claude dupin cette annonce
et 1500 euros une petite photo qui est
une petite fiole imagine qu est
quelqu'un qui va acheté 1500 euros il va
payer il ne sait pas ce qui va recevoir
est ce que c'est un dit est-ce que c'est
tout le bain est ce que ces dix titres
donc on paye 1500 euros en jeu et on
s'est dit qu'on allait s'en foutent pas
mal mais ça me fait penser que je rate
un match très intense et que c'est comme
gravir et c'est comme quand tu dit deux
avions devant un tribunal nous dit
notion de plaisir sexuel de redon redon
on peut prendre du plaisir dans son bain
ça soit sexuellement
moi j'adore
pardon mais si les deux minutes
d'acheter 10 cm on allait pas pour
l'amour